foreign
H-Town what's up Trey
what's going on dog good morning how are
you I'm excellent my brother how are you
I'm doing well I'm doing well and I'm
honored that you're uh that you're
taking my call and I can't thank you
enough for all the guides you can help
you've provided not only for myself but
the rest of your listeners as well you
got it my man what's up dude
my uh my question to you is do you have
any advice or guidance on how to help a
loved one while they're experiencing
Panic slash anxiety attack when you're
with them during that vulnerable time
you should call my wife dude she had to
sit with me when I was a mess man
um tell me what's going on
well uh my girlfriend she's uh she's had
a couple she averages a couple a week
um and some are minor but some are
pretty major
um almost to the point of some some sort
of I don't want to say paralysis but the
hands cramp feet cramp up lock up and
then her body just gets exhausted
um you know it's hurting sleep it's you
know doing it it's it's the whole gamut
of things so you know I've experienced a
few myself
um and I know what it feels like I don't
wish that upon anybody I just I just
feel pretty helpless to be honest with
you so I'm just seeing if I could seek
your advice and if you have any thoughts
on that have you I mean three a week is
a lot she needs to go seek medical
attention if she hasn't already is she
seen a doctor
uh yes I've actually helped her get into
a therapist as far as a doctor goes
um I haven't I'm not sure if she's gone
that route yet but I can definitely
touch base with her yeah
um that's a lot
uh that there's a lot going on there
um
so real quick panic attack is it comes
out of nowhere it's sudden right you're
driving and all of a sudden it's this is
it I'm having the big heart attack and
I'm out
um is what it feels like and anxiety
attacks are they're slow builds
generally right they build and build and
build and build it's like being an
advice until finally it you just burst
right like if you took a Diet Coke and
just put it in a vise and squeezed it
until it finally exploded right
um
what's the root of her panic and her
anxiety
uh honestly doc she uh she unfortunately
lost her niece unexpectedly
um a couple months ago okay um it was a
it was a traumatic deal
um it was it was very sad it even
affected me some to some degree to be
honest with you
um so I don't know that uh that that
that was dealt with
um and then I had a couple of Health
scares myself you know about a month
after that so it kind of shifted the
um the priority or the focus from her
niece to myself
um and then you know getting through
what I went through the what I would
call the gamut of doctor visits and all
that good stuff
um then all of my results came back good
and then I think it just kind of is
reopening that wound that's that's my
personal opinion I'm not a doctor
um but that's kind of what I'm what I'm
thinking all right
um one of my favorite questions to ask
guys who have
um
who are in a romantic relationship with
somebody
um what's going on is I want to get to
how you answer the question and you
answered exactly how I would have
answered it exactly how it answered it
and I'm going to tell you that my guess
is you are possibly contributing to this
which is awesome because that means you
can be of
um part of the solution is that cool
yes sir please
um so she your your her niece died
suddenly a few months ago how many
months ago
uh the end of July okay so very recently
yes sir okay the phrase you used and you
may have just been spouting it out but I
want you to imprint this on your heart
okay the phrase she hadn't dealt with
that
um this will be something that's
felt that that ricochets through her for
years
so this isn't like hey the check engine
light came on and you need to go get the
oil changed and you just never went got
the oil that's not what this is
this is um probably her brother or
sister right lost a child
she had an identity as an aunt she had
an identity as
um she was gonna like this is something
she's thought through for years and
years and years and this little child
suddenly passes away in a traumatic
fashion I mean you see what I'm saying
so this is something that is now altered
there's a before and after with her
and the more as the chief person in her
life right the the guy she leans on
the more you try to fix that or solve
that
the more it compresses her ability to ex
to feel it
and that shoots kind of comes out of her
body in all sorts of crazy ways like
locking it down or trying to fight
something or trying to run from
something and though you've heard the
old fight or flight right yes see what
I'm saying so what she's got to do she's
gotta I mean she's gonna see a counselor
I don't even like the words I don't
something about your relational Dynamic
I I went and found her a counselor she's
got to be willing to go get well
that's what I'm saying she's gonna have
to walk through that that she's got to
walk through hell and you can be with
her but she's got to make that walk and
the more you
um make the calls for her make sure she
goes to all the appointments check in
there's this strange reinforced
helplessness that that begins to cycle
through see what I'm saying
yes sir and you love her don't you
yes sir and you want to do everything
you can to help
absolutely and it's so hard when the
have you ever been in the weight room
are you a weightlifter
uh yes or played college football so
very familiar okay you understand this
like the spotter can really help
but the the less the spotter touches the
bar on on the bench press the stronger
that guy's gonna get
right yeah sure and so you want you
don't want to see your person that you
love crushed by this barbell and so it's
easy to jump in there early help pick
that bar up everybody feels like they're
winning I got the bar up I'm tired you
got to help
but nobody's getting stronger
see what I'm saying yes sir so
um I want you to not think of her as
something to fix she's not broken her
body's doing exactly what it should be
which is it has freaked out and then you
got sick what happened with you man
uh I had a uh I don't remember the
doctor term but I fell over hit I
blacked out hit my head
um and then woke up in a pool of blood
and then went through the whole gamut of
doctors and did all the the CT scans
brain scans harp scan all that good
stuff
um haven't even passed that many tests
in school to be honest with you
um but uh but yeah there was just a uh
it was pretty it was pretty up and down
for the for the three weeks following
the uh or the month and a half following
her niece passing away so imagine her
like let's take her cognitive
functioning for a second let's put that
aside
her body has just experienced a
traumatic loss of her niece
and suddenly the person that she sees
the rest of her life with
Falls over and hits his face on the
ground and you know as well as I do all
those the doctors are like well it could
be brain cancer and it could I mean
that's where they start right and it
could be that you're having an aneurysm
they they go to the worst case scenario
and work backwards
um they don't often start with blood
sugar or fainting or exhausted or hadn't
eaten they start with end of times
her body has already put a GPS pin in
that trauma everything can go away at
any second
yes sir and then 60 days later boom the
man that she loves might be going away
too
like I it doesn't surprise me one bit
that her body is rattling through time
and space right now
so whenever I hear somebody who's
struggling with anxiety
um by the way like
so I tell you to tell you she's not
broken she's not dysfunctional she's not
falling apart
what she needs is healing not fixing and
those are two radically different words
fixing is we've got to turn a wrench I
gotta fix your meds I gotta adjust this
up a little bit
um I need to put your bone back in like
your shoulder back in the socket healing
is
I'm gonna come over
and I'm just gonna sit there and hold
your hand
and we're gonna write a letter to that
little niece together
you see what I'm saying
yeah sure and she's going to be a
tearful puddly mess
and you're not going to say all right
all right stop crying and you're not
going to say any sort of you need twos
or you should none of that language
yeah sure you're just gonna put your
hand on the side of her face and you're
gonna hold her
yeah sure see what I'm saying and we're
gonna do this over and over again and
then we're gonna go for a walk
absolutely and what we're doing is
whenever somebody tells me that they're
anxious they're struggling with anxiety
here's the three places I go connection
um safety are you safe are you being
abused are you in a toxic work
environment and autonomy do you have
control over what happens next and right
now autonomy has been completely
stripped from her
one almost two people who she loves just
poof we're almost gone one of them was
gone the other one almost was gone her
body is telling her you have no control
over anything
the second one is it's scary to find
yourself completely alone to have your
brother or sister lose a child and you
don't know what to say you know what to
do
and the third one is everyone starts
trying to fix you
right and your body gets disconnected
when everyone's treating you like a
widget like a like a dysfunctional
lawnmower or a broken lawnmower
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to reintroduce connection back
into this relationship which means and
you're going to think what are you
talking about dude I talk to her all the
time we text all the time I show up all
the time
what you're doing is you're giving her
information you're not connecting with
her
yes sir okay so here's your homework are
you ready
yes sir we're going to today when we get
off the phone I want you to spend some
time writing her a letter telling her
how much you love her
telling her you're not going anywhere
man
telling her that you are going to stop
trying to fix her
and you're going to start being with her
and then I want you to read that letter
to her face
number two
I want you to ask her
not show up and tell her ask her
what do you need today
what do you need this week and she might
say I don't know I don't know
and you can say well I'm gonna come over
unless you told me not to
I'ma come over I'm just gonna sit with
you
we can watch whatever you want to watch
read what you want to read do whatever
sing whatever you want to say I'm just
gonna sit with you
I'm not gonna try to put the moves on
you I'm not gonna I'm just gonna come
sit with you
and here's what you do when you show up
her body will do this
oh
and when you ask her hey what do you
need
you're going to slowly reintroduce
autonomy to her she's gonna get some
little bit of control back on the only
thing on the planet she can't control
which is her thoughts and her actions
and she can speak her needs out loud and
you can say got it I'm on it
we're gonna stop parachuting in to solve
all of her problems and we're going to
hold her hand while she stands up
and my my we're argon also she needs to
go see a doctor and uh make sure get
some make sure her heart's working good
make sure she's okay but it doesn't
surprise me at all
um she needs to keep going to her
counselor
and I I'm willing to bet if you'll spend
some time
really grieving the loss of this little
one
you being honest about how scared you
were
that you thought man this could be
really scary I might lose her be honest
with her tell her those words Trey I
know it's not a cool Houston guy thing
to say but tell her I was scared
I thought you were gonna lose me and I
don't want to lose you
now we're not we're not avoiding the
hard stuff
we're getting right in the middle of the
grief and we're gonna sit in it and
we're gonna own it and we're gonna find
out over the next two months three
months six months
is suddenly the light comes back on and
her body goes oh you're connected you're
safe you're driving again
we can stop with the anxiety we can stop
with the panic
so let's start there
she is really really lucky to have you
my man I'm grateful for you